See, your comfort zone is secretly
ruining your future. It feels safe and
easy. And that's why it's dangerous
because easy feels good today, but hard
builds the life you want tomorrow. So
every time you avoid something
difficult, then you train your brain to
stay small. But the moment you do one
hard thing like wake up earlier, start
without motivation or face what you
fear, then something changes. You stop
reacting to life. Then you start taking
control. So when the morning, even in
the small way, and the rest of the day
feels lighter, stronger, and more
intentional, because discipline isn't
built in comfort. It's built in those
quiet moments when you choose hard over
easy. And I've explained all 10 habits
that can transform your life in 2026.
And if you're interested, then watch my
full